obviously there have been talks about a
film adaptation of Mean Girls the
musical have there been any talks for
you to join that cast as Regina yes I'm
doing it you
were yeah so oh my God okay so you get
the call from what Tina Fey like how
what was your reaction I was excited man
I was excited I was on the treadmill I
was at home and I was walking and I had
just finished a day of like college
girls filming and my agents called me
but also my mom like rushed into the
house and it stressed me out so like she
was like Renee because she obviously
knew because everybody in my family and
on my team was in cahoots like everybody
knows everything before I know it
um and so I was so stressed because I
was like what's going on what's going on
I thought I was in trouble
and then I wasn't oh my God yeah that's
major congratulations thank you you're
the first person that knows about this
there's a lot of first going for you I'm
so excited for you wow that's so
exciting uh what do you think Rachel
mcadam's reaction is gonna be Mommy
I love her I love you Mommy
yeah in a respectful way I'm gonna say
it's in good hands Regina George is in
good hands and plus of course you
performed on Broadway people are always
like Regina you're so cool and beautiful
and popular I wish there was more of you
to go around what do you want fans to
know about what you guys were are going
to cook up for this film I feel like
what we're cooking is like
gonna be a very exciting authentic take
on like what Mean Girls is and what Mean
Girls was to us as kids that's what I
think is so cool because I understand
that like a lot of things get like
remade and a lot of things get like
breathed sort of new life into it and it
just feels like okay why are we doing
this for me it's so sick because Mean
Girls was such a big part of my
childhood so now I'm like oh this is
what this meant to like me and my
generation 100 and it's a huge impact
and what Tina did is Big so I'm just
thinking we need to light our prayer
candles and recharge our crystals to get
Lindsay Lohan to like maybe make a
little special cameo in the movie don't
you think it's her Renaissance she's
back you get it see the girls who get it
get it cool
it's my turn to catch up how many girls
are you talking to 30. Okay so sexy as a
college girl season two uh what can you
teach about what's ahead because we do
know that Alicia is coming back Alicia
is coming back which I'm so happy about
because I love Midori and I love just
like acting with her and just getting
you know getting to be around her as a
person but
um I like would be such a liar if I said
that like I actually remember what
happens the rest of the season so fun
fact I'm actually just finding out with
you as it errors because I don't
remember I like blackout I believe that
yeah yeah I do yeah do you have like
viewing parties when the new episodes
drop are you kind of watching it quietly
at home by yourself no I don't
no I mean I watch it so I I see so much
of it on the internet before it actually
goes up so like sometimes I'll I'll
watch the shows I think I'm actually up
to date right now though yeah I'm not up
you you're caught up
I was about to ask I'm sure your girl
Alia is going to be in the crowd tonight
right
Aaliyah did you know she got Cassie Mean
Girls before Oh my God
knew she knew before me
yeah you did you knew before me Adam
told you at dinner before I knew
you know how to keep a secret I do it's
my responsibility no wait do you
remember the episodes more than she does
like neither of us
blacked out you film it and then it just
goes away yeah
yeah it's like for you guys watching it
back then it's
one I'm really proud of everyone
so good I don't know it's exciting I
mean it's cool to watch it back it's
also like kind of a jump scare sure I
feel like I feel like every time I sing
on someone's face is weird especially
like seeing you like yourself make out
with people like no one's supposed to
see that you know actually bye you kind
of like that I kind of like that I'm
like oh my God she's hot I'm like who is
that good for you
you were in the 2L video
um what was that it was so fun we were
just like gooping around and it was late
and we were Delirious it was cute yeah I
feel like you've built a community on
Tick Tock because Chris Olson was in it
and uh Dylan was yeah I mean is that
platform I don't know mean something to
you oh my God your homie I love Tick
Tock yeah I love it I feel like I live
on the app I also feel like
yeah man like Tick Tock is such a big
part of my career you know it is like
you make music I love it and Tick Tock
like tick tocks in tandem your music
career and your tick tocks are all in
one totally also like Dylan and Chris
are like the girls and so it's really
nice to like be able to just have like I
don't know I'm very stupid stupid lucky
to have such good friends in my life and
friends that are willing to just like
that was a Saturday like just like take
off their lives on a Saturday come to
set with me for an extra like 12 13
hours and just like hang out come to the
Troubadour on a Tuesday night like I
wouldn't miss it for the world she's
going through tour I remember that yeah
we're doing it I love it
[Music]